[Musik]
das wasser
hat vorjahr
sogar zwölf minuten
murat ernsthaft
herzlich willkommen zum live-ticker
sommer und zwar ist es wirklich richtig
einfach mit einfachen zutaten und wie
gesagt es wird halt machen und wenn man
es gab einfach und simpel und primitiv
sind möchte ich euch meinen freund
zeigen und zwar der macht mir da auch
mit lukaschenko kennt ihn der
bundesbeauftragte für kleinkriminalität
in duisburg ändern und zwar mein freund
bin auch deshalb
[Applaus]
auf jeden fall wird das eine ganz tolle
geschichte ich freue mich jedes mal
binnen wenigen wir zusammen kochen darf
und wie gesagt wir machen ganz ganz
einfach ist das her das nennt sich anna
das creme brulée kennst ja schon mal
trendy ist französisch
kommt aus frankreich
ok alles da nicht
mal was mir für diese
so was mir für dieses tolle rezepte sind
natürlich andere hast genau ich habe mir
zwei handels warum warum habe ich die
kleine anderes sagen egal habe wird es
schwer etwas dabei gedacht haben und wir
reden darüber also wir haben fangen wir
mit den zutaten ganz ganz easy wir
hoffen dass manchmal die fünf einheiten
aber ich zähle erst nachdem wir uns
ansprache gemacht haben fangmann
okay für dieses rezept braucht ihr zwei
große ananas braucht zwei eier 4 eigelb
dann brauchen wir eine prise salz dann
brauchen wir 50 gramm zucker
120 ml ananassaft
einträge vanille extrakt und 90 gramm
koks nicht dass ihr dafür du monceau
publik gemacht
der reis reichweite bieten zimmer aber
ganz anders agiert diesmal nicht
passieren
der in meiner sagte auch warum jedoch
kam er doch soviel kinderzimmer und
jetzt weiß halt immer so wich zu
erlangen es geht nicht um ihr
geliebter frankreich
alles
okay alles da wie gesagt hier sind die
zutaten die krieg nämlich überall die
zutaten hierzu der anders natürlich ich
meine es hat mir schon wahrscheinlich
schon mehrere professionelle videos
gesehen anders auf die reif ist erkenne
darin bildet den strom hier oben raus
sinken dann ist die reifen strupler ja
was ein thema das habe ich schon öfters
mal beobachtet da klopfte man alle
nachdem hört aber es kommt nichts sagt
wir wissen übrigens 2 ab 3 ananas die
gibt es bei mal bei mir ab trainer hat
schon mal werden es ist ab juni und ist
eine abwertung hat und zwar ist ganz
ganz easy so einfach so
jetzt kann ich meine
so die kann man einfach den strom
abdrehen musste gar nicht schneiden naja
hab sonne jetzt siehst du wieder
so machen einen strom weg so richtig
cool und ist toll ist auch man wenn man
so einen anlass also man kann es
wirklich am strunk merken oder und man
kann auch an der andere anders riechen
so
die richtig richtig durch gehört noch zu
drohen oder
die ist noch nicht so durch
und wer sich schon an bereich schon
überreicht dann kann man auch machen am
kam es ja auch erkennen habe ich mal von
einem freund der ist schnell erzählt ja
und jetzt fangen wir an diese anders
schreiben nehmen diese anders
entscheiden zuschneiden richtig genau
machen wir es mal so nimmst du deine
habe ich in meiner studie nicht zu dünn
und zwar haben wir hier möchte du sollst
du sollst dann lasse ich weiß ja wenig
daran lassen hat doch gesagt es mache
halbe halbe dann macht ihr macht vier
scheiben aus der gkv
stelle mathelehrer mache eben genannt
und ist gleich war es angst dafür ja
gesagt hat stimmt doch gar nicht muss
doch erst oben schneidet und da oben
noch vorhanden sondern es ist ein koch
wieder ruhig leute was beibringen oder
oder ich steche fragen werdet millionär
du amateur mach mal mama ding heißt wir
schneiden jetzt anfangen so wie ich das
dann möchte würde ich auf jeden fall den
ofen schon mal vorheizen auf 175 grad
und ober und unterhitze genau kulas
abgelesen du bist eine liste vom
telegraaf richtig und denkst dir
wirklich er ist hier realist
abgestimmt du kannst kann ich jetzt gab
es mitgenommen du lebst instinkte du
bist nur durch insider 48
ok also vor
[Musik]
also ich sag jetzt mal die arschbacken
vorgeheizt und jetzt ist eine kleine
ananas deswegen ich mache jetzt drei
stücke aus diesem auf vier stücke ich
mache das jetzt wie ich es möchte nein
doch ein paar also
durch so du sagst kitteln ja mach ich
auch
wahnsinn oder so
ähnlich große teile
dreiteiliger und es ist daher richtig
cool auch immer hier zu schrot also
etwa anna eingeteilt da wo man die 33
gleiche teile
auseinander
selbst
wenn man gott her und du bist du blöd
und pudding an die wand nageln
gehört
hat kann zu behalten kann ich sofort ja
machen
so jetzt kommt der schwierigste part
dieses rezept ist wirklich ein völlig
ohne spaß der schwierigste part des
rezeptes und zwar haben wir den 313 1270
protel die kugel aus schneider vom bfs
steht ein ausstecher genau mit einem
ergonomischen griff den mann so halten
kann und dann muss man die dinge jetzt
aushöhlt und auswählen heißt aber nicht
bis zum boden sondern den boden brauchen
wir nach hat damit die creme darin hält
das heißt ich habe sagen wollen wir
darstellen warnt genau so schlecht auch
uns das mal gerne stehen und stehen
lassen kennt sich aus das allein hilft
thema dran sind je nach alter 215 sind
noch 3 1 wollte sagen und das gibt es
jetzt so
und jetzt tolles ausfüllen
wenn ihr sohn aus wieder nicht habt
könnt ihr zum beispiel auch ein bisschen
länger ausstechen tschuldigung version
ausstecher nicht habt dann könnt ihr
auch wirklich hinter den schafen löffel
[Musik]
also ich brauche ich jetzt kann man im
löffel wir dürfen jetzt ein bisschen
schwierig ist wie sie trinkt man braucht
ein bisschen länger bis zum normalen
office
den strom komme es jetzt haben die
anders ausgehöhlt er ist ganz ganz
wichtig ich sag's ihm noch mal was
zusammen meisten nicht wegschmeißen
daraus stimmung nach irgendwas machen
ich weiß nicht was wir werden meister
lag ja mit anderen einmal was verlag
so jetzt habe ich hier den topf und da
müssen jetzt ganz ganz wichtig auf die
reifen achten den top-platz nicht zu
heiß man wirklich absolut auf mittlerer
stufe und als allererstes macht diesen
andernach gesagt rein und ich sind
andere nach sagt ihr müsst ihr
vielleicht nicht extra kaufen weil ich
habe jetzt die asse herausgeholt den
sagt könnt ihr auch daraus holt oder den
passionsfrucht oder orangensaft wird
auch noch passen dann muss ich nicht
extra kaufen solltest du jetzt hier rein
und
es ist ganz wichtig nur auf mittlerer
stufe nicht heißt weil als nächstes
durch die ein rein und wenn es heißt
werden die als zuerst rein tun wir
hätten plötzlich spiegel einen desktop
nicht so schön
jetzt einfach verrühren dann nehme ich
noch umstimmen
schneebesen sorgen dann nehmen wir noch
genug zucker
und jetzt an schuss von den extrakt
kann man sich gar nicht zu viel rein
machen eine prise salz
so
soll jetzt einfach hier und jetzt einmal
der tampa hatte ein bisschen hochgezogen
auf 60 70 grad das war jetzt bei mir
behalten was anderes ist bei mir stufe
ungefähr 5 das ist so ein bisschen
anblick das ist ein bisschen dicker wird
das ist das was die eltern mit ihm
gemacht haben wir haben so lange
geschüttelt bisher angelegt ist ein zeit
wird dieser so
genau schön an war
früher
[Applaus]
ein lastwagen gegen die türe auf da bin
ich mal reinkommen okay ganz schön krass
und zwar dieser nette herr hier ist
nicht vom hauptzollamt und zwar ist das
tristan brandt manche milch nein du
nicht du bist halt
ich rühre ich höre dass lahm ist und
zwar es ist kein fake ist jetzt echt
eine spontane aktion finde ich cool also
gerade da bist und mitten ins video ein
geplatztes christan ist zwei sterne koch
und gehört zu den trainer schon ich
früher schon das ist an zweiter stelle
gehört zu den 50 besten köchen der welt
nach meiner mutter nach meiner frau ist
natürlich der beste koch und war und
nach und nach uns genau
das was wir
machen ananas und ich muss jetzt mit ihm
zusammen machen weil wir sowieso ein
pfleger
aber krass ist etwa dass tristan brandt
kennt ihr vielleicht auch aus
küchenschlacht erster auch ihr ohr hat
hier in heidelberg also kann man eine
viertelstunde von uns hat da ein
sternerestaurant und 19 59 59 stand das
so aber ist ein gutes pflaster ist kein
stempel hatten ständischen freundin
amanda crew gehabt
ich habe
juni hat kein stern
die hat kein staat werden immer
kritischer
er hat ja schon gestanden genau so war
er gar nicht dieser läge ja ich gebe dir
gleichen stellen weil wir haben du
siehst ja genau so stelle ich mir leid
kristina fister an dass du
wir haben wir gucken uns erst einmal die
künftig helfen kann ich musste
ok ich rührt das ist was jetzt alles
drin da habe ich mich
gefragt
was habe ich jetzt als amateur
eier zucker
dann habe ich meine es war eine prise
salz und jetzt sieht es so lang ist wie
sun liegt so wie er zum beispiel
dass trotzdem fast was ich mir überlegt
ja früher hattest du freunde des wahren
guten spieler oder trickbetrüger oder
ein schwindler ja und heute hast du
freunde drei sterne küche und ein
ärzte-team darin lassen ja es ist halt
älter wird müssen wir aber gut man
anderes machen will ja aber
die betreuung liegen als hütchenspieler
so trist also ich hab das jetzt
ungerührt weiter weitermachen wie bisher
muss ein bisschen bequemer mittelhäuser
das mache ich
das und was einfach so oder so ist
es ist nicht so dass er ist zum ersten
mal das ist cool von uns er hat ich habe
mich schon ein paar rezepte beigebracht
für seine stelle kirche er war übrigens
überhaupt welt in ihr war in panama auf
eine ananas fällt das weiß ich der war
dann in frankreich war schon rivale
shanghai war schon genau
der hat leider keinen gips und darf nur
hinreißen
er darf dagegen darf nur ausreichend
kraft will nicht irgendwann
gehen die braucht man dann war es schon
na ja der hat der braucht die
tollwutimpfung deswegen davon
[Gelächter]
muss auch wenn die ausreichen muss dann
brauche er stimmung vom veterinär das
ist
aber jetzt schon langsam das ist
jetzt ein vom krieg christa macht einen
auf dicke hose
ich will etwas dünn amateuren ist
sozusagen nicht viel mehr gehabt hätte
als wir ankommen
so
okay jetzt habe ich jetzt mache ich den
herd aus welche ziemlich angedickt ich
sagen ich bin zwei möglichkeiten
entweder zurück weiter aber was wird was
ja oder machst du die kokosmilch nein
zum abkühlen okay da habe ich jetzt weil
es immer gut wenn die wende kommt es mir
zum beispiel und schloss an ich werde
bei damit das aroma schön drin im fokus
das geht schnell weg das ist noch mit
normalen markt normalerweise machen das
ja menschen alleine und nicht zu zweit
geld also das ist ja ich glaube wir
gewinnen und ich bei dir eine küche
arbeiten würden ich glaube dann derselbe
älter war wie erfolgreich stellen wir
die erfolgreiche
doppel x
habt doch was kommt denn jetzt haben uns
angelegt und alle die kosten sind rein
gemacht aber was ist wenn das jetzt was
aus kokos nicht reingemacht nein das
mache ich nur interessant wenn zb fokus
ist in der creme brulée kannst du auch
zum beispiel ein bisschen kokosflocken
nehmen kann sie an rüsten und kannst du
dann später mit rein machen es gibt noch
ein bisschen quatschen sondern auch
kokosflocken rüstung ja ok
[Musik]
als rezept ein bisschen geändert so muss
ein bisschen verfeinern und du hast was
vor tristan ich möchte sie die kokons
locken müssen also ich hier in farbe
kriegen und aroma machen eigentlich die
sterneküche ihr macht das ja jetzt mal
daumen also ja wir können so also für
die mängel kann man also zwei als
lähmungen führen okay zwei esslöffel
kann schnell zwei esslöffel geben
man merkt dass jetzt das merke ich jetzt
noch zwei apple ja ja ich gebe dir
gleich zwei esslöffel nach direkt er ist
nicht so dass ich hab mich auch geärgert
ich habe mich auch entwickeln und hat
schon viele gespräche im ln anliegen
gehabt und er ist einfach so 2 s
also wenn dies ohne rezept kopf da muss
schon löffel verbrauchen das ist
untergegangen kleinere 2006
mit profis gewöhnt und leider hast jetzt
nur ein bier
an mangas die merken wir machen ein hoch
bei jener kirche ist sehr wahrscheinlich
mit mit gas oder und das denken die
meisten dass wir mit gas kochen genau
und hat damit auch anders sagen nein
darfst du nicht haha ok spaß weil du es
bist darfst du zwar folgendes induktion
ich genauso schnell wie das problem bei
gas ich dass du eine umgebungswärme
daraus das heißt wir schwitzen wie die
schweine in der küche auch wenn es
vielleicht moslems sind aber deswegen
induktion zwischen früher und mehr mit
gas gemacht aber in letzter zeit nimmst
emotionen mehr mit funktion ja es geht
ja schon gemacht
du kennst dich auch mit zitrone und
studenten sich auch
wenn es riecht nach kokosmakronen jetzt
gut
okay zwei akkus flocken wenn ihr habt
das ist eine option auf die hätte ich
auch kommen können aber ich war zu sehr
mit ihnen geschäfte
ok und ist jetzt auch hier ein ja es
geht mir ein land das recht auf ok
[Musik]
ist übrigens jetzt möchte ich auch schon
frankreich ist mehrzad war so tut als
das wasser zwar genau wurde hier sagen
von sortieren also punkt vom schränken
sie ist so cool ist kann es jetzt zu
heben oder so heben sogar und dann hier
rein machen richtig spaß machen aber
dann läuft die ganze bühne herunter okay
okay
[Musik]
wir haben jetzt okay wir haben einen
fehler gemacht aber es kann auch zu
gehen das ist ja tristan na ja und zwar
ich mir haben die haben ihn anders zu
sehr ausgehöhlt ich glaube mir ein
bisschen mehr aus na ja da kann man aber
nicht reinmachen dann führt das gefühl
als füllstoff übrigen gehören weil die
stimmung gleicht nämlich alle gleise
gestellt werden weil ich da merkt man
auch gesagt aber das was von der welt
herkommen das kann mit toastbrot auf
[Gelächter]
413 spot macht der marke fulda
und den kopf verletzt haben ja genau so
jetzt haben es gemacht und jetzt stehen
die zehn minuten in den backofen
forschen vorgeheizt und dafür mit 70
grad bei 175 grad
[Musik]
nach zehn minuten und dann muss ich
daraus kann damit mit dem was
herausgekommen sind wir raus gekratzt
haben salat salat machen und zwar
in der sterneküche seiner
experimentierfreude wenn es sind wohl
darüber balsamico zu machen und danach
groß zu machen
können zum beispiel lässt ihn gewesen so
das letzte drittel ist kann man so ein
tag wo es nicht nur kurz - okay ich
berechne topfen sagen kann dass ein
bisschen ein bisschen warm haben
karamellisieren dann kommt es auch immer
noch besser zur geltung auch dagegen
kurz und holen sie und ihr macht der
rest zusammen kriegen könnten alles
gleich
das ist ein harter job ist meine eigene
tochter ist ein quadrat caravan sind
genau so und hier zitronenmelisse oder
minze melisse ich sie darum ist es
münchen das ist marokkanische minze
richtig
ok dann gehe aber weiter etwas machen
was brauchst du es ja ein bisschen goes
locken nachrüsten okay geben uns gerade
mit dem schicken oder die man später hat
weil die das nämlich jetzt dass sie die
brühe drin und kann man karamellisieren
ok und dann machen wir das an astra dazu
wird ein bisschen kleiner machen später
drunter und machen den christlichen
comics loccum hoffenheim und schön sind
was man jetzt ja wir machen das schon
okay
okay ist wahnsinn das kommt genau ist
das ist perfekt in meine tochter ist
wahnsinn okay
okay
das erste was
sie sagt sie habe ich habe das ganz cool
dass ich hole schnell warte man kann es
mal im recker geben den recker das ist
doch wecker wird sack noch aus preis
machen
hast du schon mal sowas gesehen wahnsinn
das habe ich erfunden und zwar gesamte
ja dass so ein stampfer und zwar das
habe ich glaube zwischen zwischen 97 und
99 waren waren post in dem bergdorf und
dann hatte ich da an den tag kein strom
und habe auch kein mixa kraft und das
ich will sind eingefallen sagt susanne
schneider zum beispiel
ein guter start
aber auf englischen am wetter oder aber
damit genau wie weg in
die klinik war übrigens bei dating in
der bundeswehr in der wand kanada und
zwar bei der bertelsmann
wollte ich kann auch schon englisch also
hat auch schon englisch denn damals in
winnipeg der winnipeg heißt es bei ihm
brennt
rangelow war das
stück von der bundeswehr
war dabei mangelt ist ja in kenntnis
setzte so
redet ziehen lassen heißt einfach jetzt
so lange aufkochen lassen und ist das
was uns verband ist ein bisschen
karamellisieren das live terminisiert
weil das ja der eigenen kraft von
anderen schon ziemlich viel wasser kommt
wir
haben schon noch komisches gemeinsam
[Gelächter]
1,3337 tipps aber
reduzieren heißt es nicht das ist alles
weg gekommen ist doch alles verkaufen
dann sagt er und dann aber dass du dazu
dass und ich habe schon voll oft
reduziert ist mir aufgefallen weil sie
irgendwann ihr mich reduziert täglich
was ja ja heute weist zwar irgendwann
bist du bist reduziert soll jetzt schon
jetzt sagen
wenn ich jetzt manchmal streifen
schneiden will aber feine streifen da
denke ich blättere übereinander werden
drehte sein
[Musik]
dass man jetzt mal tristan ich habe sich
die generation
dingdener leben ja so mache das auch so
wie du das die minister hätten
übereinander
es ist ein fortschritt über gesten
schneide strikt als wenn man jetzt so
strahlten schein bildern die das
gleichmäßig aus in der regel
so jetzt macht es genauso gemacht als
würdig so nett ist und so
nicht gemacht
und dann die finger richtig sicher vorne
ganze messe halten und dann mit dem mit
den fingern führen wenn die kinder führt
ja
jetzt runter wie schneiden
lässt ihn aber in alle richtungen ein
ach so ja viel einfacher wie krass die
hat vollkommen recht
weil sonst die ganzen ja blätter waren
es immer wieder gestritten messer ziehen
[Musik]
also etwas richtig cooles beim essen
schneiden immer zu da habt ihr die
geschichte ist etwas anderes wenn der
grünen ziehen deshalb jetzt brauchte
schreibt das ist was anderes
aber
kein gutes zeichen dass hertha dress eis
geschnitten und das habe ich jetzt
gestehen aber dafür ist jetzt erstmal so
in meiner technik ok direkt verstanden
worum es geht es genau so ich sag ich da
nicht auch schon gesetz ist derzeit in
patricks
am rosenbusch abstand
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
also komplett weg gekocht und es ist
noch ein richtiges sowieso ein sirup
stein sondern ein problem an kleinen
dafür oder oh ja was man hier nämlich
kurze zeit gerade noch probiert
und das ist sogar software heißt ich
habe richtig wie honig sagt dann glaube
ich
dass
jetzt wiesen karamell film der sich zehn
jahren noch nicht als so ein sch mccain
stunden zwei blocks genau in zwei
wohnungen
verstanden was es genau das jetzt
schlägt jetzt schön um die um die anlage
herum und dann geht das
schon so ein ding
jetzt alles daran dass normales jahr ein
was einmal schön heißt okay
das ist immer wieder das hammer ich habe
schon gesehen ich habe gemerkt wie ein
kanten in zwei wochen genau das ist aber
auch wie das ist billig
die idee oder so christian war es bitter
dass man die menschen nicht wir können
durch die hässlichen sondieren müssen
mehr oben drauf schauen ja ich mache
kommt na ja nicht gesagt dass
hier eben einfach weil das nach ihrem es
ein bisschen breiter ist einfach hier
drauf und zack rein siehst du das
genießer was gelernt und dann machst du
so gut auch so ganz
cool
also mit fünf minute war wieder nichts
halten musste aber ich habe mich also
halten kann das blatt ich habe damals
gehasst ich habe damit gerechnet ich
habe sogar das
ist dann kann man sagen heute ganz
geplant gehabt dass man ist alles doch
machen aber ich finde ich mit reduzieren
das ist wirklich sich dann wegen mantel
um die anders liegt richtig coole
geschichte dass man beim denken egal
wann und über welche warm gelaufen weil
es sonst weise das kalt das miteinander
und man denkt warum es macht uns aus
aber es macht schon richtig was
allerdings zusätzlich sondern ist das
eigene produkt optimal
verarbeiten april
das können jetzt noch ein paar leute
hier probieren lassen
so tristan tzara das gemacht der rest
lasse doch drinnen rechnung auslöffeln
das stück an das ist wieder so ein stück
wie schnell das weißt du warst du ich
gebe es gar nicht richtig zitieren ohne
spaß wie bei school es wäre
richtig gute küche und am wenigsten
wiener schnitzel dann zum wiener
schnitzel kartoffelsalat und ist
wirklich so drauf drauf und der kunde
denkt sich jetzt aus und ist es und wenn
du nicht mitrechnet ist es eine ganze
menge geschmack selbst das ist auch gut
so
links wie übrigens als wurde eingestellt
lacht das ist tolerant und hat sie sich
natürlich voll aus also war als als
flucht sondern auch der haushalt wird
aber wohl überrascht das war
okay
das ist schon okay
du hast du nicht warum ich dann kommen
die künftigen haben
[Musik]
dennis
tristan ist da
ja und der hat mit abstand den besten
kartoffelsalat gemacht wo wir jemals
gegessen haben wirklich mit abstand das
auslöffeln
stimme vorn hat schon wiener schnitzel
vor dir bist du es wegen der fall werth
nein es ist keine paletten ist einfach
mal was ich niemals gedacht dass ein
kartoffel hat so schmecken kann aber
kein schon richtig so genau
wissen die dritte radieschen rettich
naja fokus ja und ich mag nun mal keine
wahl
was ist denn es
ist gar keine kartoffel
ist das ist aber noch andere aus
kartoffeln und aber jetzt das gedacht
seine kartoffeln weil so ausgesehen hat
war hat er sein können mit diesem song
gut
du kannst
dankeschön
maschine
aber echt
krass waren ja
jetzt nämlich das was sie mal
war
normalerweise aneinander abgang ist
keine
[Musik]
geschichte das hat mich nicht bevor du
schon da war es dann bin ich schon
gespannt ich hab noch kleine bild erst
dann kennst du kennst du ganz klein war
ja wirklich mal wald und im alltag für
die nicht essen wenn ich mir
fuchsbandwurm wenn hier anscheinend
gezogen mal kommen
[Musik]
so jetzt aber die kleinen erdgas 51 euro
die also circa 50 euro je nachdem wie
die saison ist aber gut jetzt ist es
vielleicht 60 gramm oder ich will nicht
mehr dass sie zu hören normale frage
meine frage warum müssen wir eigentlich
alles so klein ich meine ich das kleid
ist obst gemüse und salate größte
[Gelächter]
abkühlen lassen hinterfragen auch mal
kurz in den kühlschrank stellen dass das
richtig abkühlt damit auch fest so
drei reichen mit
44 stück jetzt machen wir das ist
typische crema machst du das eigentlich
in der stelle ich so ein bisschen zu
berufen ist ja sogar 95 94 gerade mache
das vielleicht ich klassisch und
klassisch mit mit passionsfrucht habe
ich das aber sonst ist alles okay wie
gesagt es war über und dann tun wir das
richtig grad karamellisieren da freue
ich mich richtig mit diesen bussen
kenner aber ich nehme mir normalerweise
brauchen sogar ihren frauen sogar der
der wahl ist sogar der süße braune da
gibt es dann schön kann man den
geschmack geht dann wenn dann nur noch
mal
also wenn das so schön fest dass damals
kam es darauf streuen ok
aber schon richtig drauf und alles was
nicht hängen bleibt fällt herunter
das heißt jetzt nicht so viel zu brav
ist das ist so eher wieder stützen ja
genau was hängenbleibt einer panade
deswegen eigentlich auch nicht darauf
streuen und dem gipfel abhalten bei dir
ist auch ziemlich viel hin geblieben
habe
dieses obst und die kokosflocken jetzt
drauf oder erster mensch ist erst
flambieren kanalisieren und das obst of
print
ich warte ab dass die kinder wirklich in
der schulklasse ihrer leeren sagen das
waren
das ist ein spruch wo ich wohne wo sich
in den köpfen der menschen manche haben
überlegte man weiß es ja heute noch
nicht ich glaube sie meist wenn die
gummis der neue kevin okay kann
angefangen vom montag übrigens dieses
von der gv der 2270 pro firestarter
firestarter bilden die nummer
2.770 punkten
was jetzt
2770 oder
also beachten muss man natürlich dass
man das meinen sogar darauf freut und
dann möglichst zeitnah karamellisiert
weil er sonst natürlich sich auf ca das
auto muss schnell sein okay dass das
muss jetzt echt nicht das ist drauf
gemacht ist ein wenn ich dann meinen
kunden bin oder bei den bei dem bei den
leuten in nantes erstrahlen werden also
ganz ganz schnell sonst mache ich mich
auch okay
doch
[Musik]
putin ich habe schon mal haben die
gasrechnung
es muss jetzt sozusagen wieder auf der
eisfläche
aber nicht drauf schlagen weil ich denke
das ist gerade schön wenn man es an
tisch geben dann geht man rein da macht
es klack genau das ist etwas über das
ist wird sich so richtig wohl an
aber kugel ist deshalb jetzt garnieren
machen wir jetzt werden drauf wir haben
japan übrigens nicht gewaschen wenn ich
es einfach cool finden wenn man sich
schon wenn ich sachen aus einem garten
holt matschie außerdem können jetzt da
vor jahren gefassten
gibt es das auge gibt es ein trikot
schon einige machen wir in eine ecke so
er mehr reduziert so ein bisschen
reduzierten sich dagegen
führen
[Musik]
also es extrem wichtig bei euch ist es
aussieht ja genau
hauptsache billig
also das ist heute nicht gekommen wäre
ich wüsste nicht wie es ausgesehen noch
ein zweites video machen und vor und
nach tristan genau ok cool und jetzt
haben das kapiert und jetzt könnt ihr
euch jemand holen dazu bringen konnte
also ich würde sagen lassen muss sich
selbst probieren weil ich glaube wir
probieren sie immer sehr partei das ist
wahrscheinlich gut schmecken lassen sie
einen anderen holen die wir holen apa
[Musik]
so jetzt einfach fällig thun hat mühe
machen hier
was machen die japaner ist genau noch
mal zu und jetzt brauchen jemand der
natürlich unparteiischen die
unparteiischen menschen nicht kenne ich
eigentlich schwiegervater wir verstehen
uns auch nichts zu sagen deswegen papa
kommst du genau jetzt sagt der papa
probieren wie man gespannt was er davon
hält
er sagt die wahrheit ich sage kinder und
alte menschen ist an die waage
[Applaus]
die haben die taliban
die
rallye sondern am
sonntag
ich habe jetzt vorgestellte gesagt es
ist tristan der kürzlich 50 besten
köpfen der welt neben dir ist in der
kürze 50 dümmsten menschen
[Gelächter]
jetzt war es probiert wirklich geholfen
das ist eine creme denn drin okay jetzt
probleme autokratisch wahrheit sagen ich
bin ich gut schmeckt dann sagt uns dann
die schuld
ja aber sein klasse ein hellgraues
irrglauben hatte supermacht bin ich auch
notwendig auch wenn es mir schwer fällt
er probiert natürlich auch mal also
[Musik]
krass
er ist dann schön quatschen und wie
jetzt die größten posten frage ich habe
jetzt aber das wäre es jetzt für das
fest nichts für sein sternerestaurant
also man hat mir ein anderes anders
gemacht und das ist schon cool aus also
die präsentation gefällt mir schon
gut aber
schön hatte gefallen stolz auf seinen
schwiegersohn und
auf tristan auch aber auf linie nicht
gelten ja okay wir haben es fertig
gemacht und der frist und ich wir werden
jetzt noch ein bisschen quatschen und
wenn wir auf die baustelle ist der papa
es gerade auf dem rollladen dran das war
unser rezept nicht uns hätte die anderen
wir könnten zum kanal abonnieren auch
wenn ich uns frei gehört sondern meiner
frau ich hoffe wir haben so gut ersetzt
lasst einen coolen kommentar und nochmal
christian danke schön dass du den spaß
erlaubt das mitgemacht hast dass du dich
auf unserer ebene herunter gelassen hast
ja ich hoffe ich jetzt
[Gelächter]
und wir sind natürlich die normalen
menschen
er sei aber erst noch einmal von allen
juni
auf jeden fall ich hoffe wir haben
wieder blockbuster x von christa man
einiges gelernt heute riecht paar coole
sachen passiert das messer ziehen und
was anderes was andere
sagen haben die gerösteten genau den
kokosflocken genau und reduzieren haben
was redest den richtig ist alles das
alles verdammt ist dass am schluss noch
dieser schleier übrigens perfekt
also vielen vielen dank dass die
kommentare da abonniert macht es
aber
[Musik]